un nuevo estado de excepción en Ecuador
fue declarado en las provincias costeras
de guayas y esmeraldas después de que
bandas de narcotraficantes matasen a
cinco policías Este martes estos actos
de Sabotaje y terrorismo son Por así
decirlo una declaratoria de guerra
abierta contra el estado de derecho el
gobierno y contra todos ustedes los
ciudadanos no tienes en las cárceles
explosiones y ataques sicariades en las
calles y la retención temporal de 8
funcionarios de prisiones el narco
respondió a los traslados de presos que
impulsa el gobierno de lasso más de 500
desde la penitenciaria de Guayaquil el
objetivo es solventar el hacinamiento y
la seguridad de los presos son
reacciones
acciones que ha hecho la Policía
Nacional y el gobierno Nacional sobre el
crimen organizado y que lo Seguiremos
haciendo No vamos a bajar la guardia que
estas situaciones van a atemorizar pero
las familias de los presos consideran
que la medida vulnera sus derechos
queremos nosotros estamos de Aquí somos
personas humilde y queremos la ayuda de
él Ecuador vive una crisis en su lucha
contra el narco en medio de la disputa
por el control de las prisiones en lo
que va de año más de 100 reclusos han
muerto una cifra que asciende a más de
400 desde 2020